okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 I'm curious I have a guy from
the 805 who previously called me from a
city bus I want to pick up on him to see
where where he is today
guy from 805 are you with me yes I am
hey where are you calling from today I
have I'm calling from
not a city bus which is optimal sorry
that's that last time I uh I I called
you from the bus that was very stable
and it was like a long-distance bus and
right have you picked up um I had I
would like in a transfer and everything
tiny we're sideways very good alright
very good well I'm glad to hear from you
what's on your mind today
yeah so as I am oh no Bernie Sanders
just dropped off dropped out of the
Democratic presidential primary I was
wondering like I don't know where do we
go from that like what is the future of
the progressive movement well listen in
your opinion so for whatever reason
we're still having connection issues
with you today but certainly we can't
attribute it to the bus here here's my
sense I think that right now we need to
as the progressive oh boy all right I
mean I'm gonna have to let you go and
I'll answer offline here's my thought we
have to balance wanting progressive
successes today with the fact that if
Donald Trump gets reelected the country
is going to be further harmed for an
additional four years and I cannot take
any action that will make that more
likely to happen so unfortunately and
this is a tough pill to swallow for a
lot of people I believe we need to make
sure Joe Biden is the next president of
the United States I actually believe
that unless we do that the progressive
movement will get nothing done for the
next four years as opposed to getting
some small things done over the
at least two years and then maybe more
depending on what happens in the Senate
in 2022 that's my view and I know it's
too centrist for some people it's too
pragmatic for some people it's not
visionary enough for some people but I
can assure you if Trump gets another
four years we are gonna go in the
opposite direction for those four years
and it will be a very very bad thing if
you ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinka splink
ax stakes thousands of popular
non-fiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video